[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
22 days
just over three weeks away
[Music]
for you to save our democracy holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] is this is it getting Wild
in the lead up to this midterm
I guess I guess this was the way it was
gonna be there's gonna be just
absolutely [ __ ] wild in the lead up
we have Grandpa Poopypants
threatening American Jews threatening
them outright threatening
before it's too late he says
what
and then you have Kanye West now
last week when Kanye was
doing what he was doing tweeting
anti-semitic [ __ ] about Jews
how he was gonna death con whatever the
hell that means I'm not sure if he
knows what he was saying it is obvious
that Kanye West
has mental health issues we know that
it's been widely reported this is not
brand new
to the American people that Kanye West
has mental health issues
the interview yesterday that he that was
released on on I I I think it's called
drink champs as a podcast
where he went on
and they allowed him to say whatever the
hell he wanted
I don't know if you guys watched the
extended versions of this thing
there was a lot of Clips going around on
Twitter
but the extended version is even worse
it's way worse than some of the clips
that were going around on social media
the guy's not well
and gay and then this morning it is
announced that he's gonna buy parlor
who the CEO I forget his name farmer or
some [ __ ] this is Candace Owens husband
it seems real convenient
doesn't it real convenient
that the white lives matter t-shirt
debacle with Candace Owens happens just
several weeks before
Kanye West
tweets out some anti-semitic [ __ ] goes
on a podcast says says Jews and Jewish
media almost like 200 times
I'm not [ __ ] you in this interview
because you you watch the clips of it
and you're like geez this guy's office
rocker what the [ __ ] is he talking about
but he says Jews and Jewish media almost
200 times
which is a little abnormal for a podcast
interview
of a of a media Mogul maybe rapper
clothing icon I guess I I really I
really don't know much about Kanye West
to be quite honest with you other than
these [ __ ] mentally ill
he's got some issues mental health
problems he needs he can afford a lot of
stuff he can afford to buy parlor he
should be able to afford
some mental [ __ ] Health Care Jesus
Christ
now this is all [ __ ] dangerous
because really this is the more
dangerous part of this
here's here's Grandpa poopy pants little
post on fraud social which
there's more news
about fraud social that it was hey it
was a fraud huh Tony said it was a fraud
the whole time oh my god oh man
I've been calling it fraud social
the entire time
that it's been launched and now we have
news over the weekends yeah it's it's a
[ __ ] fraud there's a whistleblower
out there
and hopefully me and Gabe get time to
talk about it today because I want to
ask him about this
um because I think he did a little bit
of his own research
our co-host Gabe Sanchez did some
research into
what the hell is actually going on with
the Whistleblower but here here's what
because we want to break it down
this SPAC thing and the investment and
the merger it's all really confusing and
it makes not a lot of sense to you know
just normal average day Folk
because it's all confusing it's all
[ __ ] rich people trying to get
[ __ ] richer
that's all it is that's all it is it's
Rich [ __ ] trying to get more
[ __ ] rich off your [ __ ] off your
back
that's all it is
but hear this [ __ ]
is outright saying and you look at the
last sentence here
U.S Jews here let me make it bigger
U.S Jews
have to get their act together and
appreciate what they have in Israel
before it's too late what the [ __ ] does
that mean
what other possible meaning could that
have other than hey
we're gonna send you to your country
U.S Jews have to get their act together
and appreciate what they have
who's they the U.S Jews you mean the
Amer American citizens
that's the end of this of this post
that's the most [ __ ] dangerous part
about it
now folks everyone's talking about Kanye
and how he keeps can't quit saying
Jewish media like literally he just hit
Jewish media Jewish media he just keeps
saying it saying it over and over and
over again
it's because Candace Owens prepped him
that's that's he [ __ ] says it he
[ __ ] says Candace Owens Candace Owens
Candace he says Candace Owens almost as
many times as he refers to the Jewish
media quote unquote
but here you have the former president
of the United States
the leader the orange Mussolini Jesus of
the America First Nazi party
foreign
for the world to see U.S Jews have to
get their act together and appreciate
what they have in Israel
before it's too late folks
he's telling you who he is
and what he's going to do
here's the thing his [ __ ] supporters
are listening to him
they hear this they know exactly what
he's saying folks
they know what Kanye's saying
they know what Elon Musk is doing
when he's when he's capitulating and
communicating and sending signals for
Putin
the trumpers in this country know what's
happening they know the signals
this is dangerous [ __ ] [ __ ] let me
tell you something about the Kanye thing
about the Kanye interview
because as dangerous as the Kanye
interview is
it actually is the sunlight
no one No One's Gonna See other than
Donald Trump's
rabid supporters are gonna see this post
the ones that would actually act out
what he wants them to act out in this
post we'll see it
it's very it's but that's the most
dangerous of this all that that his
supporters his most
vile violent supporters would act out
what he's describing here in code on
this post
the Kanye part is the actual
disinfecting part now they're way
miscalculating
this is all this is all in in p a PR
stunt
to get parlor to be popular because
truth social is about to [ __ ] tank
true social is gonna tank it's done
it won't exist probably within the next
year
it will be gone
and the only reason why you know it'll
be gone is because Donald Trump can't he
can't stop posting about it's the
greatest thing ever since since ever
ever in the history of ever ever he's
like oh it's number one above apple and
Facebook and Google and blah blah blah
[ __ ] block
thank you
it won't exist a year from now folks
true social fraud social is done
it's done
Jesus Christ it was created in the image
of Donald Trump everything Trump touches
turns to liquid [ __ ]
absolute liquid [ __ ]
and I believe that farmer and Candace
Owens
in an attempt for a big PR stunt all the
way back to the White lives matter
t-shirt
it leads all the way back there
because Kanye this morning is announcing
he's gonna buy parlor which
good luck to parlor they just sunk that
[ __ ]
for sure
Kanye's career is is he he's
self-destructing here
but again the Kanye part of this whole
debacle where these people are just
seething
and frothing
for American Nazism
these fascists out there
who were dying I mean they're oh they're
excited about it they're really excited
that Kanye West is on the bandwagon
here to blame the Jewish media for
everything
we have went
from Grandpa Poopypants here riding down
the golden escalator
and demonizing
people coming across our Southern border
for jobs the American dream
for Asylum
demonizing brown people people of color
and now they have worked themselves to
be full on it is the Jews
folks
I've been telling you they're the
America First Nazis
literally the America First phrase is
born
in Nazi fascism
that's what the Nazi in the 30s in the
40s in this country that was the
movement here in this country for Nazis
was the America first movement
oh I didn't have anything to do with it
the words just seem to be the same
the cat calls
that they're giving here and this is the
this post here is the most dangerous
signal that we have seen for fascism
in damn near 100 years
this post right here
the only reason why you need to see it
is because yeah you're going to hear
about the Kanye West stuff
you're going to hear the interviews
you're gonna see the footage of the
clips of the Kanye West interview and
the podcast that he did I think it's
called drink Champs something like that
I don't know I don't know much about the
show that he was on
to be quite honest
um I'm actually glad that they let him
talk
sunlight's the best disinfectant let me
tell you something Kanye West was fed
all of that garbage all of it he was fed
that [ __ ]
he was fed that nonsense
oh Kanye it's just the Jewish media
getting at you the JP Morgan Chase thing
that's just that's just the Jews
he was fed every single little bit of
that
every single little bit of it just like
Donald Trump here has been fed a steady
diet of anti-Semitism and white
supremacy his entire [ __ ] life
this country is [ __ ] built on it
people
for you to stand around and act like
white people even me aren't aren't
[ __ ] bred racist you are a dumb
[ __ ] you are a dumb [ __ ]
and what better way what better way than
to convince
in their minds a voting block
that it's the Jewish media that's coming
after the black people
Kanye West even says in this interview
that they are they are Jewish black
people are Jewish which there's there it
doesn't seem to show in the glitch as
opposed on social media but there is a
little pushback
from The Host
and and what he says is look if if
you're really saying that the black
people are Jews
then why are you then why would you
speak so so adamantly against
Jewish people if black peoples are Jews
all right
it's confusing I know really confusing
to watch Kanye say some of this stuff
he doesn't have much context of history
or or really facts
he's been spoon fed what he's supposed
to say and what he's supposed to hate
and who's coming after him
how do you think this works
how do you think it works
they distract you
you [ __ ] trumpletites out there they
distract you
with a with a an enemy that isn't really
your enemy
of false
sense of an enemy
while they strip away your entire
individualism and your rights that's
what they do that's what they did in the
1930s and 1940s in Germany it really
isn't difficult to understand and really
uh all you gotta do is I don't know read
a [ __ ] book every once in a while
Jesus just watched a couple
documentaries on this second world war
for crying out loud just a bit just just
something something
look at a timeline
of Hitler and the Nazis
because this isn't this isn't Italian
fascism this is not Mussolini
this isn't this is not Mussolini
this is fourth Reich
Nazism
he says in the post U.S Jews have to get
their act together
and appreciate what they have in Israel
before it's too late
what the [ __ ] is he talking
listen American citizens here in the
United States
who were Jews have ties to Israel in
most cases
that's probably a thing but some of them
are not Israeli
most of them are not Israeli they don't
even see themselves as Israeli
they are two different countries
two different political Dynamics
dangerous [ __ ] A Dangerous time we're in
and it's very volatile
so who are you gonna pick
that's the real question that is before
us
because you can't stop Donald Trump from
posting on fraud social you're not gonna
do it you're not gonna stop Kanye West
getting in front of [ __ ] microphones
and saying some Bonkers ass [ __ ] you're
not gonna stop him it's not gonna happen
that's not how it works
you're not going to stop Elon Musk from
communicating with Vladimir Putin it's
not gonna happen
it won't happen
those are things that we cannot prevent
you cannot prevent that
so what are you going to do about this
there is one goddamn thing you can do
and you can engage
in this midterm
there's plenty to engage in this midterm
because this [ __ ] this [ __ ] that's right
here on the screen this [ __ ]
statement right here from Grandpa
Poopypants again is the most dangerous
step
towards America First Nazism
since the 1930s
dangerous [ __ ] [ __ ] he wants to
be Hitler
threatening America's Jews oh yeah it's
a great idea
because because let me tell you
something the the um the American
especially the ones The Descendants from
the victims of the Holocaust yeah they
don't remember that at all
folks
we have to protect our brothers and our
sisters
regardless of how they feel or what
political affiliation they are religion
color of their skin
rather they're they're not paying
attention to what's happening in
politics
rather they aren't paying attention and
just missing the entire
real problem that we're having
it's up to us
we have to [ __ ] yell and scream
this is dangerous [ __ ] now again the
Kanye interview the Kanye interview
where he's talking and rambling on and
on and saying just [ __ ] that doesn't
even [ __ ] make sense frankly there's
[ __ ] in there that just you can't even
it's not even computable at some points
when he's talking about this stuff
that is the sunlight of this
disinfectant because no one no one is
paying attention to Donald Trump no this
statement right here no one is paying
attention to this statement no one no
one's paying attention that [ __ ]
besides people who worship Him who think
he's some kind of God which is a low
percentage in this country
yeah
remember that
but they pay attention to Kanye West
why do you why do you think Candace
Owens and her husband the the CEO of
parlor is is is is is trying to do this
power grab
in right-wing social media
that's what this is
don't get it twisted
the White lives matter
the tweets
the interview the announcement this
morning was all coordinated
it's all coordinated because they see
the demise of fraud social
someone's got to be the king of the
castle King of the castle
and that's their plan
and frankly I think they're using Kanye
West
they're using his anger they're using
his outrage they're using his bias
they're using his mental health state
as their game because he's an amplifier
he's a megaphone
but I believe if that's an over
calculation it may be great for parlor
oh it may be great for parlor when when
when ye or Kanye West well whatever he
calls himself now
ye buys
parlor that may be great for parlor
it's going to be terrible for the
America First Nazi party
you don't think people are white what
did Kanye say
people who have no [ __ ] idea
who's Even in our government what the
government even is they go vote and
don't even know who they're voting for
they heard this Kanye thing you damn
right
damn right
they heard the Kanye
interview they see nose clips
this statement that I have here on the
screen from Donald Trump where he's
threatening Jews here in America
and and that's what he's doing
he's using his voice to get his people
riled up
and and to Parrot this thing
and to keep saying this nonsense and the
sentence at the end is the most
important part I mean I gotta read the
whole [ __ ] thing
but it's the ending that they're gonna
hear that they want that's what he
delivered to him
this whole rambling [ __ ] statement
here but Kanye West is going to get into
the ears of a lot more people than
Donald Trump
I know you think well Tony that's
ridiculous that's ridiculous everyone
knows who die well everyone knows who
Donald Trump is but do they listen to
him back no
[ __ ] no
why do you think Candace Owens and
farmer are using Kanye West
in this PR stunt to have him be the most
attractive most attractive buyer for a
right-wing media social media platform
that will just swoop in and take the
place of Donald Trump by the way the
same platform that basically planned the
Insurrection if you remember I know it's
been almost two years
but this parlor was the goddamn platform
that basically planned the insurrection
and the big lie
playing the whole goddamn thing was
coordinating on that app
that's why [ __ ] Apple and Google took
the son of a [ __ ] down for a while
until they got their act together on
moderation
the saw that but the Kanye thing is all
PR stunt but it's an over calculation
and the reason why is because now people
are gonna see like whoa he's blaming
what on who
this really feels like uh what's that
what's that called World War II who are
those people in Germany what was that
what was that um
nutsy Nancy Nazi
folks if you were standing around
wondering
if these people
were Nazis
then you weren't paying attention but
you should now
and you can do something about it that's
the most important part here that's the
most important thing you have to ask
yourself
is what can I do well what you can do is
engage in this midterm
you have the ability to vote everywhere
in this country
every single state is going to have an
election every single District
is going to have an election
you may not be electing senators in your
state with your vote but your
representatives maybe Governors State
legislators council members of your
county or your school board
it's time for you to be pro-democracy
unapologetically and to not tolerate
intolerance
[ __ ] them
it is time to [ __ ] use our ballot to
punch these Nazis it's time enough is
enough of this nonsense this Q Anon
trumped up Nazi [ __ ]
laughs
number one why in the [ __ ] would anyone
who's experienced any Liberty at all
even just a little hint of it in their
entire life want fascism number one
number two why would you want these
[ __ ] buffoons in charge of anything
anything
absolutely
anything
folks you are the best audience in the
world and you are growing we are getting
big here on the Tony Michaels podcast
the audience grows and grows and grows
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch thank
you for joining us
make sure to follow us here on YouTube
don't forget to subscribe do not miss a
single thing
you're not going to want to miss
tomorrow tomorrow's got Texas ball I
want to talk to him about this
we're gonna probably talk about this all
week this is the most important thing
that you can talk about yeah Steve
bannon's going to go to jail there's all
kinds of stuff going on but listen to me
when I tell you this this is the [ __ ]
the alarm Bell hey hello thank McFly
think
why would anything but a Nazi say these
type of things
are convince someone
to go on a podcast to wear t-shirts that
say White lives matter and then start
yelling and screaming about Jewish media
and Jewish Banks
it's crazy [ __ ] it's crazy [ __ ] what he
was saying it makes no sense like the
[ __ ] that he says in the extended
interview it makes it even worse it
makes him look even more like a buffoon
like he's being uh coerced into saying
this stuff and believing he's deluded
loose
Kanye Jesus Christ dude get a grip
someone get that guy some [ __ ] Health
Care quick look I'll tell you that you
guys are the best audience in the entire
world and I do mean world all around the
world everyone has been ordering this
shirt the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty go to
store.dtonymichaels.com I got mine just
the other day I was I was supposed to
wear it but I forgot it back here on the
chair maybe I'll show it to you here at
store.tonymichaels.com you can also get
you a hoodie we have zip up hoodies
there too all right so don't forget to
check out the coffee mugs the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty
it's it's the most popular thing right
now that we have on the merch store it's
crazy we even have some dark Brandon
stuff
and we have the Dank Brandon design
still
here's the uh here's the shirt that I
received the other day in the mail again
I I forgot to wear it this morning but
it's a blue one it's a great shirt great
shirt go pick you up a t-shirt a hoodie
a zipper putty
or a mug that helps us support that
keeps us going because we run on your
support here at the Tony Michaels
podcast and if you want to give us a tip
a one-time tip or a monthly tip you can
set it up monthly go to Tony Michaels
dot live slash tip Tony Michaels dot
live slash tip you can also watch there
at tonymichaels dot live you can watch
there every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and also from the books of face make
sure to follow us on Facebook if you
guys are on the Midas touch Facebook
Channel make sure to go over to the Tony
Michaels Facebook page I post a lot of
memes and some other social media Clips
over there so go follow at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook and also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google make sure while you're there
subscribing that you leave us a great
review we need those reviews
we run on your support again it is up to
you folks and we appreciate every single
bit of your support whether it's you
guys buying these the freedom to oppress
the rights of others
is not Liberty that is great support
your retweets your shares people are
sharing this like crazy on Facebook
sharing it like crazy on Instagram
going to Tic Tac
so thank you for all your support
everywhere no matter what that support
is you are the best audience in the
world and I do mean world everybody
stick around we're gonna go through this
shitless Roundup because we got a lot of
these clips I want to get to our co-host
and executive producer Gabe Sanchez is
going to join us he's back he's back
he's back he's out of the he's out of
the phone booth he's out of the deep
State phone booth everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break it's Monday we got 22 days until
the midterm election for you to save
your democracy it is the most important
election of your democracy's lifetime
it's hanging in the balance here
thank you
I know that seems kind of crazy but let
me tell you these statements from Donald
Trump and Kanye West and the fact that
Elon Musk
is out simping for Putin and the
Republican party still has a tweet they
still have a tweet up that says Trump
Kanye Elon or some [ __ ] I don't remember
what order it's in does it really
[ __ ] matter those three names are on
the tweet
so they're all in they're balls deep on
Elon Kanye and Trump and here they are
here we are in this moment 22 days from
the election Donald Trump is calling
and threatening the United States
Americans Jews some weird thing about
Israel I don't know he's calling Israel
their country and we have Kanye West
attacking the Jewish media as if almonds
problems are from
only
Jews I know this is really anti-semitic
[ __ ]
and then you have Elon Musk privately
communicating and signaling messages
from Putin to us to the world he's
basically his mouthpiece and that to the
Republican party's like yeah on their
side fat
think about that for a second
think about if we let the Republicans
give Donald Trump Elon Musk and Kanye
control
over the world just imagine just imagine
that's what you want
and on top of that holy [ __ ] there was
some
ah some crazy debates
over the weekend oh we got so much tape
to show you tape what is this the
[ __ ] 1990s Jesus Christ we have so
many clips
we had so many
tape like I got a [ __ ] VCR back here
or some [ __ ] oh my God
we got so many Clips to show you today
in the shitless Roundup just because of
the Kanye
problem that we have
um
and the uh the debates
that we have that we had going on this
weekend
uh
Herschel Walker
he uh he pulled out
twice
which is rare for him
it's rare for Herschel Walker to pull
out he pulled out a uh a fake Toys R Us
badge at the first debate and then he
pulled out of the entire debate all
together the second time
and he just no one was there just an
empty podium
so Herschel Walker breaking news pulled
out twice over the weekend which is a
very rare event indeed
apparently Virgil Walker because also
this morning we found out more Herschel
Walker news that yes he has confirmed
that yes the check that he wrote for an
abortion is his check he did write the
check for the abortion of course he did
of course how could he deny it it's his
[ __ ] check with his signature on it
okay it's not hard to figure out [ __ ]
Herschel Walker's autograph
and then at Herschel Walker's check it
really is not difficult to figure this
these pieces of information out how they
thought they were going to deny this for
a whole month
now here's this craziest part about it
all
the greatest part to me
is that people are still listening to
the polls in Georgia that is the
craziest [ __ ] thing I have ever seen
in my life
listen uh I think it was let me go find
it here I want to show you before we go
the [ __ ] list I know I'm showing you
tweets before the [ __ ] list but
um this is very relevant
um uh Midas Mighty Matt had a tweet this
morning and it it's so great
he's so correct he's spot on here
he said you know who who polls are
really in really important to
politicians just just politicians
polls mean absolutely nothing to voters
unless your goal is to vote with the
popular group
that's the politician's goal by putting
out the polls and the media is to get
you convinced that there's a candidate
that's winning over the other one it's
up to you it's you Matt goes on to say
vote as if your vote is going to decide
the winner
stop saying Democrats gonna lose stop
saying that [ __ ] they may lose in some
of these races but stop saying it go
vote like they're gonna [ __ ] win like
you're gonna win like democracy is gonna
win what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
people
he goes on to say vote as if your very
life is on the line
just might be he says just vote thank
you Matt
everyone should spread this around like
wildfire all over Twitter
this is so important stop [ __ ] paying
attention to the polls stop it stop it
doesn't mean [ __ ]
it doesn't mean a goddamn thing if you
just take what you saw if you're in
Georgia if you're a voter you take what
you saw
the weekend and these debates Herschel
Walker
and Warnock and then the Marjorie Taylor
green one if you're in her District holy
actual [ __ ] this is crazy ass [ __ ] just
use those pieces of information [ __ ] the
polls polls don't mean [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] the only poll that matters is the
one you're marking your [ __ ] ballot
in that's it that's it that's the only
poll that matters is the one you're
marking your Battlement that's the one
that counts
so um give Matt some love and spread
this tweet around
it's a it's it's a very great point
it's a very great point
stop paying attention to the nonsense
and get with the time
uh we're waiting on Gabe Sanchez he's
going to be here in just a few minutes
the phone booth was it was um it was
hard to get away from probably I mean he
has phone booth hangover probably
so let's do this let's go to the
shitless Roundup where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends
again a lot of Clips to show you today
start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Michaels podcast we have reached the
segment where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and train turns that's a bulk of
what we do here is just go through the
news and show you the [ __ ] that you need
to see to make decisions that you are
supposed to make maybe show these clips
to a view of your family and friends is
the lead up to the election we got 22
days we're just over three weeks away
folks from this election the most
important election of your lifetime
and let me tell you the authoritarians
around the world are not excited about
Democrats winning let me say that again
authoritarians
dictators murderous pieces of garbage
around the world
are very nervous
if Democrats win
you got the Saudis pissed off
the Democrats gonna win when you got
Vladimir Putin very upset
when Trump
and the America First Nazis are losing
their minds
because the Democrats could possibly
keep the house take the Senate some of
these Governors races are on the
chopping block for Republicans Democrats
can take those races
they're pissed off listen we got them
right where we want them
that's the important part to know
is that if they're if we got the right
[ __ ] people pissed off
we got the right people [ __ ] scared
if the authoritarians
are losing their minds
because Democrats have a chance
to save this democracy
that's what we that's what we want
that's that's the enemies we want to
have
those those are the enemies that we want
those are the enemies that we want Putin
man yep then we do not want to be his
friend
Trump and his America First Nazis not a
thing that we really want to Cozy up to
tried that no not gonna do that again
you want to see some of this I'll show
you proof here here's a Ken hands this
this is the uh one of the Saudi the
Saudi princes I guess I don't know I
don't know who these [ __ ] are
I don't know their names here's is when
the Saudi Isaac cousin I guess
I don't know brother cousin to MBS the
uh Captain bones all
laughs
and he's saying this [ __ ]
as Democrats are critical of OPEC which
which is Saudi Arabia
the Saudis
raising the price by cutting production
now they're they're really pissed off
they're really pissed off that the
American people because here's what's
gonna happen
is it gonna happen they thought that
they could control the world's oil and
they can control us
most places around the world if you
don't know this because you're [ __ ]
listening to dumb [ __ ] on Facebook
most of around the world the gas prices
are higher than they are here the reason
why is because we have high production
of crude here we can produce a shitload
of oil a lot of it
in this country
we actually have
Surplus so much so that we have an
export
we export oil around the world
our production is at a very high high
and one reason why is because these
[ __ ] murders pieces of [ __ ]
are threatening to lower production
around the world so we must increase our
production in this country to keep
prices at a decent level at a level that
is reasonable the problem is is that
people don't make enough [ __ ] money
in this country to afford fuel we have
some of the lowest gasoline listen
lowest gasoline prices around the world
folks don't let the dummies convince you
that we don't they're full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] listen if you are happen Upon A
Trump supporter like fake game I don't
know if he's here today or not if you
happen upon one and they start talking
just know that they're full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] every single bit of it the whole
thing line by line by line by line all
of it is all [ __ ] yeah I think Gabe
Sanchez agrees and then Gabe you agree
with me on this it's you can't trust
them for anything you can't trust them
to watch your dogs you can't trust them
to give you basic human rights you can
can't trust them when it comes to
anything when you have some [ __ ] Mega
bro who wants to say hey look according
to the way that markets work uh
they want to be the ones that tell you
exactly how gasoline prices are dictated
and that's not it they don't know they
took maybe one one day in a in a uh an
econ 101 course learn about the 1970s
gas oil crisis and then we're like oh I
know everything I need to know that
applies to today exactly exactly the way
it applies today well here's here's a
video of of a Saudi Prince really pissed
off if Democrats win and the reason why
is because democracy wins these people
hate democracy there's a reason for it
they're authoritarians let's listen
foreign
and this Kingdom
all of us we are projects of jihad and
martyrdom
that's my message to anybody that thinks
that you can threaten us
okay so there you have it he's basically
saying oh by the way when we want to to
control the price of crude around the
world because we're going to control
production we're going to decrease
production if you challenge us on that
you're our enemy like how in the how in
the [ __ ] can't we get this straight that
Saudi Arabia
in Russia are not our allies over the
weekend we watch China Gigi ping make a
huge move China is in bed with Russia
and the Saudis as well folks this is
super important and these people do not
the murderous dictators
the authoritarians around the world do
not want Democrats in power
because Democrats are pro-democracy and
they do not want this country to hand
over the voice of the people because
they know that it's not going to be good
for them that will not be good why do
you think Vladimir Putin is using Elon
Musk as his little walkie-talkie what
the oh why the [ __ ] do you think that's
going on this is just crazy that the GOP
still has that tweet up uh it says Elon
Trump Kanye or something like that have
you seen this yeah no I I I've I've seen
that one of course they're not going to
take it down why would they ever take it
down those are the reasons this morning
I think
I don't know if you were tweeting about
it I have one that's that's waiting in
my drafts right oh okay which is related
to this whole parlor situation oh really
yeah well we're gonna talk about
coincidence folks I'll say yeah well it
seems kind of funny it seems like a big
uh PR stunt uh really done up by
um not Trump but Candace Owens and uh
farmer her husband who is the CEO parlor
to take the position of Trump's true
social because true social is is is
gonna crash into the ground it's not I
mean it's basically
um well every one of every single right
wing app and I'll probably end up just
based on the stuff that I heard this
weekend over like The Whistleblower I'll
probably end up doing what was that but
on the overall topic of right-wing
social media apps they [ __ ] suck
because they don't know how to design
because design
spoiler as a designer here design is
driven by empathy and when you have a
group of people like conservatives and
Republicans Maga whatever you want to
call them they don't have the ability to
actually understand what empathy is they
won't actually design something they
won't actually build something that that
that is creative and on their own they
will steal from places like Twitter and
other such things that don't reinvent
the wheel and then then they say wait
wait why isn't it working why aren't
people here I mean you look at like the
right stuff
the conservative dating app and you're
like I mean the white stuff you mean
that yeah yeah the white stuff right
exactly which is like wait wait why
aren't there more why aren't there more
women here oh it turns out that women on
the on the right don't actually want to
date these [ __ ] douchebags on the
right crazy
I mean how how in the world did did they
not do their market research like all
the dudes that end up in in in DMS
showing dick pics to girls on the
internet DMS those are the same dudes
are gonna sign up right
stuff which you know in California you
can be sued up to thirty thousand
dollars for sending an unsolicited dick
pic what yeah are you serious yeah now
that's just like picks in general so you
can't send a picture of Ted Cruz to
someone
[Music]
um
what qualifies as a dick back game I
mean you know California needs to be
careful about there yeah
yeah
I don't know
is that the I just showed the picture of
I think that's the uh yeah that was the
tweet that was the one that they I mean
those are their those are their freedom
fighting wannabe Pro House Independence
okay this is the house Judiciary okay
now this this is the the group of
Republicans in the House Representatives
that are in charge of the oversight of
the Judiciary right so the bench
and they tweaked
three names and and I I think
this is the thing that is flooring to me
that it's the Judiciary Committee that
is tweeting this they tweeted Kanye
period Elon period Trump
period
I don't I don't know if they're like you
know father son Holy Spirit I mean I'm
Catholic so I grew up doing the I mean
it it very well might be that uh I have
no is that Creed still up by the way I
think I I think it's still up let me see
now regardless it still lives in infamy
that this thing still exists now this
Kanye stuff is really [ __ ] dangerous
did you did you watch any of the
extended interview or did you just watch
some of the clips there on social which
ones the one with Tucker Carlson or the
no no no no no no so let's talk about
the Tucker Carlson one too but I'm
talking about the one from um I believe
it's called Uh drink Champs I believe
that's what it's called I believe that's
the podcast yeah I've seen it I haven't
watched the full thing because I was
traveling yesterday but I've seen a few
Clips I mean look it
the [ __ ] he said about
um George Floyd like we
for anyone who you know is just uh
coming up from under the Rock right now
George Floyd was murdered by Derek
shelvin right for having his knee on his
neck he couldn't breathe
Kanye goes on to the show and says the
complete opposite which is the right
wing Theory right he even brings up
Candice cell and he's like I watched the
documentary of vicanderson seems
coincidental doesn't it right again
there's no such thing as coincidence
folks everything's [ __ ] tied together
and so when you have Kanye West going on
this talk show to then blast and defame
the character and name of George Floyd
and how he actually died
by pushing this right-wing conspiracy
about it was the fentanyl it was the
fentanyl it was the fentanyl they love
that they love that right now fentanyl
fentanyl fentanyl they love that because
here's the thing at the end of the day
the medical examiner proved as fact that
he did not die from fentanyl he died
because he was [ __ ] uh suffocated
with a knee to the neck and couldn't
breathe because of Derek shovin okay
that's the actual reason that is what
was proven in court as fact
so when you have someone especially of
such a high caliber degree in the in in
the kind of
um social space as Kanye if you start
saying dumb [ __ ] right there are going
to be consequences we talked about this
on Friday there were going to be
consequences for the dumb [ __ ] that you
say and so if you say George Floyd died
because of Fentanyl and it was the
fentanyl that killed him George Floyd's
family now is considering nah we know we
might sue you because you're dragging
our family member's name through the mud
with a lie when it's provable alive
right
and he'll go to the court right open
court they went to the court record
that's how he was convicted in the first
place because the flimsy defense of
Derek chovin was that oh well this guy
he had drugs in the system that's why he
died and and the prosecution showed no
that's not why he died right that's not
why it's because you had you [ __ ]
suffocated him that's why he died now we
all know and I can't even believe that
it all comes full circle right so the
black lives matter movement is really
known to most people in this country
because of the George Floyd murder right
that is not when black lives matter
started
um the the movement and the organization
for that matter does anybody remember
when and what event caused black lives
matter uh to be organized and to be a
movement does anybody remember what
happened
um how that came to be BLM it was a it
was a guy in Ferguson Missouri his name
was Michael Brown
he lifted supposedly
a cigarillo it's always it's always
supposedly right it was a fake twenty
dollar bill supposedly right he he
lifted supposedly lifted a cigarello was
was murdered by a cop in the street
because he happened to be black in the
street after he was profiled for
stealing this cigarillo because we all
know the crime of shoplifting a
cigarillo in this country is the death
penalty [ __ ] ridiculous now the
difference between the black lives
matter movement
when it happened under in Ferguson with
Michael Brown
was that that was not on film it was not
on film now we had a lot of footage of
Michael Brown's dead body laying in the
street I live in Missouri now I I don't
I'm not I don't live near Ferguson
let me tell you something here in
Missouri it was a big thing because our
governor our state troopers the state
police was involved in this
there was a lot of chatter not just in
the nation
but in our state now we did not have any
real evidence
that that video evidence that would show
that Michael Brown was shot in Cold
Blood
it wasn't up until 2020 when a video on
the internet showed Derek Chauvin
suffocating and murdering George Floyd
with his [ __ ] knee on his neck
did the entire country go whoa [ __ ] that
is exactly what they've been saying has
been happening
and people realized what black lives
matter meant what they meant by it
that was the moment
now when you have Candace Owens here
and you have Kanye West wearing shirt
wise White lives matter they know this
is a spat in the face
two black people in this country
100 full especially when you have
someone like Candace Owens knowing her
history right and how she was all about
taking advantage of uh you know in her
eyes is taking advantage of the the
racism in this country when it benefits
her
but then will flip around and say oh
there is no such thing that doesn't
actually exist that's not real white
lives matter and especially in this
photo right here
the the smile over the shoulder wearing
the White lives matter shirt is a it's
not just oh they're just wearing shirts
and they're looking away right Connie's
looking forward but it's the [ __ ]
devilish evil smile smirk that she has
while she wears that shirt
in front of a group also
that has different black people in it
right
well and we wondered why this was a
thing right like everyone's like why in
the [ __ ] did they do this right I mean
it was obviously again another spat in
the face of black people in this country
and all around the world to be frank
but it was more than that this was a
[ __ ] setup this was the whole point
is to get them in the news Candace Owens
and Kanye West in the news
it was it was a [ __ ] setup now we
took the bait because this is gross as
[ __ ] yeah and again the sunlight needs
to be the best disinfectant here and I
believe I believe folks that this
anti-Semitism that the Republican party
is inviting not only inviting but
they're [ __ ] amplifying it with
Trump's [ __ ] fraud Social account
he's basically
threatening American Jews it's [ __ ]
overt America First Nazism now
I think they've miscalculated here and
by they I mean um Candace Owens
and Kanye West and her husband farmer
because I believe that before this
picture was taken their plan was to
announce that Kanye was going to buy
parlor but they could just announce that
Kanye was gonna buy parlor right that's
not a thing that they could do they had
to have a reason why right there had to
be a reason there had to be a a
crescendo this morning to this parlor
news
and this was the beginning and then came
the Tucker Tucker Carlson interview
about this shirt then came the tweets
the anti-semitic he says death con three
to Jews something of that nature you can
we can pull up that up I'm sure yeah
death death and I mean obviously you
know he's playing into the whole Defcon
but like
it's called Defcon which by the way
Defcon 3 is right in the middle so it's
like a mediocre like if you're gonna go
I'm gonna go Defcon 3 on someone's like
I'm gonna go moderately in the middle
but also he says it's death con three
which
is even more disgusting because you
decide to make it into a pun whether
intentionally or not like I'm being so
funny about this I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
these Jewish people like whoa dude
that's not okay yeah
it's it's Insanity now
he they go on to Tucker he goes on
Tucker Carlson right and I know you were
gonna say something about the Tucker
Carlson interview about this shirt
um before we get to the the Tweet so
what what were you going to
um say about Tucker Carlson interview in
the Kanye West well I was just gonna say
how even in the even in the released
footage the the unaired footage right
even Fox News was like uh we can't show
this
anti-semitic comment about Jewish people
being uh what was it they taught I don't
want to miss quote because it's that
gross so I will try to find it right
kind of [ __ ] grooves uh
I mean I mean and the [ __ ] that he was
saying on this podcast
um was really [ __ ] gross and actually
you know a lot of people were saying why
did they let him on the podcast why
would anyone let him say this I actually
believe that this is good that Kanye's
is out saying this and here's the reason
why folks because this is what the
Republican party wants Kanye does not I
don't think he really fully understands
what he's doing here
um he has a lot of mental health
problems we all know that and and I'm
not I'm not excusing his behavior but
he's being manipulated obviously by
other forces because he's got he's got
uh Candace Owens in his mouth when he's
in this interview and if you go watch
that full interview not just the clips
because the clips are really [ __ ]
telling but the interview makes it it
even worse for Kanye
um just in the full context of what he's
saying because a lot of those clips game
that you see on social media they're not
taken out of context there's actually
more gross context right than what you
even see in the clip like it's not like
oh someone took that out of context
someone cut that up and edited like holy
[ __ ] that would be did him a favor by
editing it if uh if fake Gabe is out
there yeah I don't think
uh fake Gabe I don't know where he is I
mean again he hasn't shown up since
Texas ball [ __ ] ripped him a new one
but what I will say is if there was
again ever a moment when you said Play
the full clip dude you do not want us to
play the full clip because it's only
going to make a situation even worse for
your argument so people like fake Gabe
who say Play the full clip we want the
full context it's like oh you want the
full-on yeah racism and bigotry and
anti-Semitism and in this in this Kanye
um in this Kanye clip you you definitely
um from the podcast you definitely do
not want uh the full context if you're
on his side which it's not a side uh I
forget I would there was someone there
was someone hey he's a troll on Twitter
I got a troll on Twitter he's been there
for a while
and every once in a while he pops up and
I posted something about I don't know
maybe we'll get to it Prager University
and Dennis Prager you see this where
he's talking about
um brothers and sisters [ __ ] and it's
not a I don't know if I've seen that one
yeah was that recently there were
stuffed last week okay well and maybe
I'll show it but um he said something
about you know another Candace Owens
graduate by the way of prageru
it's it's all it's all connected it's
all connected in the world um here's
here's the outtake of the uh Tucker girl
how long am I playing this for this is
am I playing the whole 28 seconds uh you
you could I think it's I think it's only
like 14 seconds but I mean it's only 28
seconds since okay let's let's play this
let's see um when he says it's biting my
tongue on my political opinion because I
thought it would be better for my
children and now you look up and my kids
are going to a school that teaches black
kids a complicated Kwanzaa
I prefer my kids new Hanukkah than
Kwanzaa at least it will come with some
Financial engineering
Kwanzaa doesn't you know so they don't
teach even Christmas itself
okay I I just is he just is he saying
holy actual [ __ ] is he is he saying the
[ __ ] that Trump says because Trump says
this kind of [ __ ] all the time when he's
in a room he's like well here's a here's
I got Jewish friends in the room and
they have all the money like he's like
yeah it's really [ __ ] I mean that's
what it is right you look at any
conspiracy theory you look throughout
history you look at the scapegoating oh
Jewish people were the ones who poisoned
the well and that's why everyone got
sick right like you go all the way back
and why Jewish people who represent
point two percent of the human
population
are the ones who are are villainized
they're the ones who are used as a
Target and they're easy targets to these
people to say
this group is the controlling entity of
the money this group is the one with
their little hands on it like all these
crazy
anti-semitic bigoted things that they
want to say and they want to they want
to point right I mean you've got
Margaret Taylor Green Jewish space
lasers you've got all these other
[ __ ] people who try to blow when they
say cabal you don't understand you know
they're like what they're saying they're
trying to when when white people like
Margarita green and Tucker cross and I
was yelling like oh the silent majority
it's like you guys are attacking a group
that is 0.2 percent of the world
population point two percent and you
want to blame them for all the world's
problems for gasoline prices for the way
in which the climate is for how the
election was was uh decided like all
these things of this new world order
when they want the New World Order
that's right when they when they want to
use that they scapegoat they put it on
to
even fake Gabe does it here in the chat
oh don't say [ __ ] like he'll say [ __ ]
like oh this is a Super PAC show and I
know I know Midas that's a Super PAC but
for you for people out there that's also
that's the Midas touch and there's the
Midas touch
arm which is right Super PAC which is
just for ads right well the the funny
thing is is that in most people who our
mind is mighty know this that Ben Brett
and Jordy are not shy that they're
Jewish yeah they're Jewish and and that
I believe is what fate gave is sometimes
doing in the chat is talking about how
we're part of the almost like part of
the cabal that language that [ __ ]
that nonsense that you spread uh Chris
has a great uh Point here because this
Kanye story is not really about Kanye
Kanye is the is the megaphone okay Kanye
is what they're using
um as PR stunt to take over when true
social crashes into the ground right
that this is capped this is a capitalism
story folks that's what this story is
that's why he keeps talking about Jewish
Banks and Jewish media he kept saying in
that interview I think he says 144 times
he says Jewish media in that [ __ ]
interview
144 times he says Jewish media and the
reason why is because he's saying he's
being silenced they're being silent
silence silence silence my people he
calls black people Jews he's saying that
black people are the original Jews and
he says a lot of weird stuff that
doesn't make a lot of sense unless you
know that Candace Owen's husband owns
Art and I owns but he's the CEO of
parlor
it only starts to make sense Christopher
points it out really well here he says
this is why black lives should matter to
Candace Owens by the way I was today
years old when I found a Candace
Candace's husband runs parlor makes
sense so here is a here's a picture of
Candace Owens from 2007. this is a bit
ago yep what happened in 2007 Gabe that
Christopher is referring to here this
was when Candace Owens decided that
racism was actually a thing and used it
to benefit her situation
and Sue I think it was what her landlord
is who she well um was she actually she
sued
um white folks in her town and uh and
the the problem is is that she used the
NC in NAACP right to help Sue and she
won and she won and a lot of people in
her high school and people who know her
personally have come out and they're
starting to speak out on Tick Tock
there's a ton of videos on Tick Tock
they're like this [ __ ] crazy loon
because she had a video here recently
which also is not a coincidence about
she's not gonna be part of the Black
Culture that's what she or something of
that nature I don't know I really
um to be honest Candace Owens isn't much
on my radar
but she's she's the story here this is
the Kanye story this is the story here
this she's the story
Kanye is just the megaphone he's just
the amplifier because the other thing
too you you talked about this Crescendo
right and so what people need to realize
is that
there were you couldn't just be like
Kanye West is gonna acquire parlor
people like what the [ __ ] right that
would be really weird it would almost be
as weird as Elon Musk tweeting he's
gonna buy Twitter right and then he's
under federal investigation you you
can't jump
from a to c right and be like whoa how
did we get here right I just jumped a
track however if you set up let's say I
don't know interviews right you you get
him to start speaking out publicly you
get an appearance from Candace Owens at
his fashion show you get you know like I
said I was like uh she cozied up and she
groomed Kanye that's that is the core of
what happened here she cozied up groomed
Kanye took advantage of someone who is
who has mental health issues and is what
seems to be not seeking help or not
under medication like he was previously
you know based on prior events and you
know pulling up in Wyoming and all this
different things right he's even come
out he's like I'm bipolar or I have
bipolar and I believe it's a situation
where
Kanye is not medicated right now he is
being taken advantage by someone else
you know who has his best interest at
heart as he might say and they make a
public appearance they have some
statements together he goes on to Tucker
Carlson's show he makes some more
statements right he gets banned or
suspended from social media which is
Twitter and says well now I need to
stand up for my First Amendment right I
can't be canceled I'm uncancelable yada
yada yada Jewish media Jewish media
Jewish media exactly it goes on this
talk show continues to just bombard them
with conspiracies about Jewish people in
the media Hollywood who controls what
talks about Candace Owens and her
documentary about George Floyd actually
dying from fentanyl not dying from
having a knee on his neck for nearly
nine minutes because of Derek Chauvin so
he pushes all these things right and
then when it's like oh George Farmer's
like oh yay's gonna bring what we needed
at parlor for so like here's the thing
parlor has raised I think 56 57 million
dollars that [ __ ] app is so it
is barely holding on right now it's
garbage it is failing they are not
getting the actual user base they need I
think La they saw a huge spike in 2020
because of it was an uh a limited what
they used to plan the Insurrection right
right but also because it was limited
moderation there wasn't you know big
Tech and big government big brother
coming in to suppress your voice you
could say whatever the [ __ ] you wanted
well that's the reason why Apple took
them off the Apple store and then the
only way that parlor was able to get
back on months later is when they
actually put moderation uh in in force
they actually enforce the moderation
not until September were they allowed I
can't remember if they were originally
allowed on Google app of the Play Store
but they made their appearance back in
the Play Store in September of 2022 so
just this past or just this past month
previous nicely so here's the thing to
go from uh hey here's Kanye and Kanye's
buying parlor everybody's like whoa
what's going on you have to search you
have to build up certain events to build
a base of understanding especially on
the right being like yeah he hates
Jewish people I hate Jewish people White
lives matter of course let me giggle
like a little boy Tucker Carlson of
course you do of course they of course
we only love white lives matter because
White lives are the only thing that
matter in this world so when you get
these things boom boom boom boom you
line them up and you discover that
there's actually a through line that
says
Candace Owens most likely if not totally
groomed Kanye into saying these things
and believing these things taking
advantage of a man with mental health
issues then saying great we got him
right where we want him he got suspended
he needs an app and alternative we'll
say Kanye is the voice in the town in
the culture we need on this right wing
failing uh social media app and then
you've got someone like George farmer
who's like exactly we got this George
farmer right here exactly this is which
no one knew before this morning who
George farmer was man [ __ ] why would you
know why would you want to know who the
CEO of a failing app was now the reason
why we know this morning is because it
is announced that Kanye is gonna buy
parlors gonna buy this app this person
is the CEO and he's married to Candace
Owens all at the same time while true
show is gonna bite the [ __ ] dust they
are going to crash into the ground there
are people probably gonna go to prison
over true social after what we what what
the news was this weekend and really
honestly I believe that all the
right-wing media knew that this was
going to happen they knew this [ __ ] was
going to happen and farmer has
positioned himself really really well
here to really sweep up all the white
supremacists to come to his platform
again that they bailed on him and and
that is his that's his play and you also
and you also have to understand who
George Farmer's father is who is his
father
so George farmer his father is a uh
Michael Michael Farmer so Michael Farmer
has uh is a Christian conservative donor
no you don't say donates millions and
millions of 12 pounds you mean he's Rich
come on
yeah so the actual I think the the
author of one of the articles I was
reading about today went in he went in
it was like just you guys know Michael
Farmer is one of the people that was
like you know funding and backing brexit
uh surprise surprise
um well when you hear when you hear
Farmer's voice here you'll understand
why that's significant because this
looks you know like I don't know he's
just a white dude right now he's not
just a white dude listen because this
clip is not that long it's just a minute
this was on Fox Business this morning
let's listen to him talking about Kanye
buying parlor it's really [ __ ] it's
really weird actually listen Okay West
uh we'll acquire this and what this does
for parlor
so I mean I think there's a couple of
things to be said here the first is that
um
parlor needs needs yay in many ways uh
because Paula needs this brand to expand
and I think yeah is very interested in
expanding his social media presence what
motivated this for him was of course his
Banning from other social media
platforms and this is a trend that we've
seen with so many different people uh
Instagram Twitter closing down his
accounts uh expressing you know
discontent with wrong think uh on his
part or at least tweets they weren't
happy about and of course this motivated
him like many other influencers and
celebrities of High Caliber stature to
come across to us and to have this
conversation with us and when that
conversation began he said you know
actually this is kind of something that
I really want to be involved in and as
his uh quote in our press release went
out this morning you know he said that
free speeches is is an inalienable hey
West okay so they've been have he admits
they've been having conversations for a
while yeah so this is not this is not
like oh he just decided to buy it
yesterday because of this interview
right I mean there's a point I don't
know what happens which happens first
but you know there is a point when I
wonder when Kanye will
realize
he's been hoodwinked here right he's
been taken advantage of he's been it's
the same thing for the presidential
campaign
well I mean yeah I mean people running
him in States they were getting
fraudulent [ __ ] right right [ __ ] he
he he he almost he almost edged up to
being a criminal himself just because he
was the one that they were collecting
these petitions on in these states that
to try to torch to try to torch uh
primaries so that way Trump could win
these states or some [ __ ] it was a hair
brain scheme really stupid cook that
[ __ ] up yeah and there's also a part of
me that wonders so this deal isn't
supposed to oh sorry this deal is
supposed to take place in close by the
end of Q4 2022 which Q4 runs between
October
to December right the end of December
until we hit the new year so at some
point before the 2022 ends you know I do
Wonder does he realize what's been
happening does he get back on medication
probably not you know he's clearly uh
separated from Kim Kardashian so he
doesn't have that support system going
on he probably only is around people who
enables him which is people like Candace
Owens same White lives matter Jewish
people control the media this conspiracy
that conspiracy
so when I look at this I do Wonder like
will he figure out what's going out like
what's going on before the deal closes
and can he argue that you know he was in
the right state of mind because of his
mental health condition maybe but I
don't know if there's anyone there to
kind of correct the path that he's on
because
unfortunately I don't think there's
anyone over I mean like even in that
interview he talks about he goes after
the Kardashians he goes with the Jewish
people he goes after oh yeah
here's a clip here's a clip
um because he's talking about all kinds
of stuff that that Jews are responsible
for in his life like right like they're
out to get him it's it's weird just just
listen to a little bit of this I just
want the family back together
Kim is a Christian
on TMZ I just saw yesterday they said
Pete Davidson and Kim have sex by the
fireplace to honor their grandmother
is Jewish zionists that's about that
life that's telling this Christian woman
that has four black children to put that
out as a message in the media
what so he is blaming he is blaming
I don't know what the hell the checks by
the fireplace thing is I have no idea I
don't follow Kim Kardashian or P
Davidson on social media I know they've
had some weird [ __ ] going on but here's
the thing
there's a lot of people who do
and here's the point I want to make yeah
there's a shitload of people there's a
shitload of people who follow these
people on social media they follow their
every move their every motion everything
they buy everything they Hawk
it's all recorded they're right out
there in the open and millions of people
are following them
including Kanye West
and yesterday no one
no one not even the media is talking
about this [ __ ] this threat that
Trump threw on true social to American
Jews
no not even the media is really paying
attention to this this morning because
they think it's not the same as this
it has everything to do it's all the
same
it's all the same because what Kanye is
doing here is he is the megaphone for
parlor to say Hey you anti-semitic
America First Nazis we are going to be
the platform where you're going to
reside when true social fails yep that's
why Donald Trump is saying the [ __ ] he's
saying is because listen I said this
I'll show it to you I I know it's
[ __ ] repeating myself over and over
but I can't can't you just can't doubt
me here I'm telling you this is what I
said about it now I took his clip uh or
his little the
the true social post the fraud social
post here it is and this one here let me
read it now that last part of it is the
worst part but let me read it it says no
present has done more for Israel than I
have he's not the president by the way
um what somewhat surprisingly however
our wonderful evangelicals are far more
appreciative of this than the people of
the Jewish faith so he's saying that
Evangelical Christians who voted for him
here in this country
are more appreciative that he done more
for Israel than any other president it
doesn't make a lot of sense
but he's trying especially those who
live in the U.S
he's talking about Jews that live in the
U.S now here's what he's saying he's
attempting to say this but this is all
code talk what he's saying to white
people who who are [ __ ] Nazis he's
saying hey Israel is different it's
different it's their country it's theirs
it's the Jews they need to go back to
that where have you heard this before
Gabe have you ever heard someone tell
you this you need to go back to your
country that's what the [ __ ] he's doing
here
that's what he's doing they don't belong
here is what he's saying he's saying
they don't appreciate what I did and US
evangelicals did for them and their
faith so they need to get the [ __ ] out
because he goes on to say those living
in Israel
though are a different story
highest approval rating in the world
could easily be prime minister
he's basically declaring himself King of
the Jews here
the ones that live in Israel because
the other ones haven't gone back to
their country even though
Jews in this country are American what
the [ __ ] is he talking about yeah well
that's the whole thing where I I mean
like Republicans evangelicals they love
Israel but they hate Jewish people in
America it's that's why they love Israel
though right right that's that's that's
they love Mexican restaurants they love
to go down to Mexico to the [ __ ]
beach to Cancun when the when it snows
in [ __ ] Texas and the power shuts off
they love that they love they love
Mexican people in Mexico they love Jews
in Israel they want white people here in
this country right that's what white
Christians is what they want in this
country that's what the white Christian
nationalism is about it's they're
[ __ ] Nazis they're Nazis this is this
was the slow walk to the Holocaust in
Germany in the 1930s and the 1940s this
was the slow walk Hitler came to Power
by blaming Jews that were Communists
coming to Germany and destroying Germany
and they needed to send them back to
communist Russia that is how it started
folks go look at the [ __ ] up
and this is what this piece of [ __ ]
garbage is doing and he says U.S Jews
have to get their act together
and appreciate what they have in Israel
he's telling them go back to your
country before we kill you before it's
too late
he's threatening American Jews I don't
give a [ __ ] how you want to spin it how
you want to talk about it what you want
to say the former president of the
United States who is under criminal
investigation in so many facets just go
watch Sean Hannity he'll probably roll
the screen here soon about how many
[ __ ] crimes this piece of [ __ ] has
done and we find out more and more and
more just over the weekend about the
[ __ ] app that he posted this on
this [ __ ] is threatening
threatening
Jews in this country and they have gone
far beyond when he came down the
escalator calling brown people coming
across the port border rapists and
murderers they are now they are now
they are now one step away from what
they want is an American Holocaust folks
I don't give a [ __ ] what you say you can
oh Tony you're being ridiculous just go
look at your [ __ ] history books go
look at how this [ __ ] works
I think this is the most this is way
more vile than the Kanye West stuff the
Kanye West stuff is just a pool I mean
you've got a you yeah I mean the big
difference here is you had a you have a
former president a one-term failed
president taking out his frustration and
his
insane racism and bigotry and
anti-Semitism into this uh this app that
he runs that he removed himself from the
board so he wouldn't get subpoenaed for
questioning he put a Fall Guy you know
uh uh uh cash Patel and uh Devin Nunes
who know nothing about running social
media companies or technology companies
in place like this guy
who is who is posting this on this app
right now is the former president like
when has a former president ever
publicly went out and said yeah so these
American Jews better get their act
together like what the [ __ ] is going on
and not only that but it's like oh it's
not just a sound bite he literally
posted it on this app and he's kept it
on this app and he thinks it's totally
acceptable and the Republican Party who
really is just trumpism now is totally
okay with him saying this
they won't correct him they won't they
won't condemn him they won't say oh hey
let's uh let's step back a bit here
you're coming a little too hot with the
anti-Semitism no no one has said [ __ ]
when it comes to the Republican Party
everyone has accepted that this is now
just well that's Trump and
that's what he does and he's gonna say
he's gonna speak his mind and that's why
he's such a great candidate and that's
why he was such a great president bull
[ __ ] [ __ ] nobody should stand for
this nobody should stand for the racism
that comes out of this group no obesity
stands for the bigotry the anti-Semitism
nobody would stand for the misogyny
nobody should stand for any of the vile
things that the Republican Party comes
out with and that other Republicans go
oh man that's my party because that's
what they do not one Republican no I
think I think I've seen Megan McCain
Megan McCain sent out a tweet she's like
I gotta I gotta get in front of this
because they're going to say no
Republicans and she's going to want to
be on the list of Republicans that
condemn this yeah here's the problem
with any of those people that go oh whoa
I'm Republican but I'm not that kind of
Republican right if you're still in the
Republican party and you only have an
issue with one small thing they did one
little bit of fascism but you're okay
with the rest you're part of the problem
and you will get grouped into that group
group because you have not condemned and
spoken out against any of the other
things they've done taken away women's
rights trying to trying to use
Venezuelans as political bonds who are
seeking uh uh who are who are seeking
um Asylum right which by the way also
[ __ ] just went right back into Ron
DeSantis face because now those people
who were sent over to Martha's Vineyard
have now been getting been given a
special Visa because they were victims
of his crime so they're all like anytime
they try to own the libs by being racist
or bigoted or whatever it is it comes
back and it slaps them right in the
[ __ ] face but no one no one
from the Republican Party actually
speaks out and if you've been okay with
all the other things they've done again
you're part of the problem you are part
of that Republican party that is your
Republican party unless you leave it and
do some other [ __ ] and say this is not
what I'm doing I want to go independent
I want to go Democrat whatever it is if
you're still part of the party and
you're voting down that ballot red and
you don't speak out against the things
that they do that are so terrible
you're that Republican party that is you
and that is Megan McCarthy or Megan
McCain let me let me be clear about
something
because this is this both sides of this
is dangerous the [ __ ] that Kanye is
saying is dangerous but you should hear
that Donald Trump has posted is it way
more dangerous because again I want to
say this and I said it dude is telling
you who he is
his supporters are listening to him they
hear him the most dangerous of the
dangerous of these [ __ ]
moglodytes the most delusional
are listening to him and you should too
you should see the danger that is
happening here they're frothing at the
mouth to go fight for this cause
you should be willing to fight for the
cause of democracy equality and equity
and to shut this the [ __ ] up it is time
we bury these [ __ ] under mountains of
votes not just now
but in 2024 now is the time though now
is the time and this is the lead up
this is the lead up
this is the most important election
right now 22 days were just over three
weeks away for you to tell them to [ __ ]
off
that is what you can do here is you can
engage in your democracy and tell them
to [ __ ] off right I mean remember Trump
trump let these people out in terms of
letting he Trump opened the closet and
let the boogeyman out and these people
since 2015 2016 have been like oh
finally a guy who speaks to his mind
finally a guy who's as racist as I am
and it's okay because he's a candidate
for the presidency and the Republican
party is okay with it and he was elected
and he was put into office and he
continues to say that stuff
I could be racist I can be bigoted I can
be you know any of these things that are
against anyone who isn't white anyone
who's not from this country
and because he made it okay
he doubles down triples down quadruple's
down on this type of stuff where he
makes a post like this and now those
followers like you said they're
listening and they go great [ __ ]
awesome I can now go do hate crimes on
people in the Jewish Community I can now
go do this I can now do that because you
know what Trump said American Jews are
the problem and they better own up they
better go back to Israel is what he's
saying
um speaking of crazy ass [ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ]
is and again I've been saying if these
[ __ ] people are weird weirdos
they are obsessed with your children's
genitalia I don't know why I it's got to
be some again it's got to be health
issues mental health issues but here's
Marjorie Taylor green
in the moment in the debate that I think
is probably the most important when you
want to shine a light on these [ __ ]
sickos is when she's talking about
Marcus flowers has said nothing nothing
on the campaign Trail nothing
about what she's about to say listen
crap party the Democrat Party is the
party of child abuse it's the party that
represents grooming children and
sexualizing them in school teaching
anti-white racism in the terms of CRT
education and genital mutilation of kids
kids that can't even get a driver's
license can't get a tattoo and cannot
vote how do you stand there and
represent the Democrat Party as a father
and do you believe in genital mutilation
of children under the age of 18 and and
these puberty blockers that have severe
Health consequences what in the why why
the [ __ ] are they so obsessed with
children's genitalia they are absolutely
[ __ ] obsessed with it why why are you
weirdos so [ __ ] focused on what the
hell is in someone's pants you are
[ __ ] weird it is weird [ __ ]
that you guys are so [ __ ] been out of
shape over what genitalias and whose
pants it is getting weirder and weirder
for her to accuse to put CRT critical
race Theory and genital mutilation all
in the same shiv to send to Marcus
flowers right really [ __ ] weird it's
gross
and it's not surprising that she is
needs some Mental Health Care again
um I want to show you another moment
here
when
when she's talking about
um because this just shows this is
Republican on brand this question they
ask is about what is she going to do for
her constituents or what has she done
for her constituents specifically she's
like oh I want to kill big government
government funding bad so I went and got
federal grants for cops because I like
Federal money money Federal money good
your question from Marjorie Taylor green
all right Miss green since taking office
on January 3rd 2021 what is the one
specific accomplishment solely on behalf
of the 14th congressional district that
is most important to you well I tell you
what it's been hard to pass any bills in
a democrat-controlled Nancy
pelosi-controlled House of
Representatives a a a a by the way
that's how our Congress works yeah
that's that like that's how it works
when when a party wins the majority in
that house
then they elect their leader either the
majority leader in the Senate or the
Speaker of the House in the house like
that's that's actually just that's just
how it works right the Senate that is
controlled by one vote with Kamala
Harris as the Democrat Vice President
also how it works that's also how our
constitution works like there's no it's
not a [ __ ] secret if it's 50 50
that's what the vice president is there
for that's why they are the [ __ ]
leader of the Senate they preside over
the Senate they get only get the vote
well not only but most of the time only
vote in that instance where there is a
tie to not have a tie if that's also how
it works also
she's in the house she's not in the
Senate so this argument of like she's
barely in the house by the way right
yeah I mean she doesn't have any sort of
yeah when when the question was you know
what have you done right for your
district 14 as a representative in
Congress she brings up the Senate like
oh well yeah okay they're controlled by
we're not controlled by the Democrats in
the Senate we bet we have a 52-48 split
and when we do go 50 50 then yes the
vice president which is her role comes
in for the tiebreaker and that's how it
works but also again we're not talking
about the Senate you're in the house do
you even know where you are when you
have your job right like you
what like what is your job your work
like why would you even bring up the
Senate and try to blame someone some
other
people on that on Capitol Hill then look
at yourself and be like well in the
house let's only talk about the house
right now not the Senate like don't
don't don't bring up someone else and be
like oh it's their fault you expect her
not to blame someone else for her what
what she does wrong okay so she goes on
here
this is this is one of the best parts
she goes on to tell us what she's done
for her constituents and a white house
that is controlled by by democrats
that's how it works now what we've done
to accomplish things for Northwest
Georgia is I'm proud to be able to bring
in money via grants to help our local
sheriff's department and help local
businesses there we
okay so I don't know if she knows where
grant money comes from I'm not if she's
really sure what um there's a word Gabe
that comes to mind it starts with an S
um
yeah yeah
um so I can't remember social
ISM that's it that's it maybe someone
should go where look at the definition
and post it in the chat here so everyone
knows what socialism is holy [ __ ] this
this [ __ ] cake she's such a [ __ ]
such a [ __ ] that she's like the best
thing that I've done for my constituents
is socialism right not not only not only
for public entities like police
departments and Sheriff departments but
Private Business she's bragging she's
bragging about how she got socialist
money for private business in her
District
well also the [ __ ] that who voted
against the infrastructure Bill and run
around states with [ __ ] chicks taking
credit it's
it's socialism right they're okay with
socialism as long as it benefits them
but as long as as soon as a Democrat
wants to do something like hey we want
to use these funds for the larger
majority of our country because that's
how we work uh they go oh look at these
fascists trying to tell me how to it's
like do you do you know what socialism
is you know what fascism is you know
what communism is like they have no fire
they blend them all together and then
they you know they basically like swap
out the words for when they want to use
them and say well Democrats are fascists
because they decided that they get to
choose who gets what when they get it's
like they made us wear masks no one made
you wear masks but beside yourself you
chose to go to these places that require
to wear masks during the pandemic so you
know what everyone else says I mean you
mean like private places no no no no no
no no no no no I mean I mean I mean they
didn't stay in their house
but you you know what I mean I mean but
you've got to remember you had private
entities wait wait wait capitalism
you're gonna make us say the s-cism word
again all right you're gonna make us say
the S is a word again
socialism they just don't understand it
she also doesn't understand how like um
um the internet works yeah like she has
no clue she doesn't understand it that
once something's on the Internet it's
always on the internet
here is the moderator trying to get her
to
um
to admit that she doesn't I don't know
check [ __ ] before she says it if it's
true or not
she has a history of doing this it's
very obvious why would she why is she
right well what's funny is is he really
he slaps her on the hand here because
he's she says really something really
stupid and he gets after her here which
is great
um because she can't really say anything
yeah because she knows it's the truth
because she's done this before remember
when she went to the Holocaust Museum
because she was being [ __ ]
anti-semitic oh and she's like I learned
so much which again I you know I I saw a
comedian uh as a Jewish comedian that
was
um she had a set and she was like
she's like of all places to send someone
who is anti-Semitic you would send them
to the Holocaust Museum that's like a
[ __ ] play day for them right they're
going in like oh man look at all these
crimes things that were done against
these people can we do this again okay
let's listen to Marjorie Taylor green
here
and we need to what can you tell me give
me an example no you do this every time
we have a debate where you I ask a
question that's obvious and you're like
what you mean you were kicked off with
your committees for saying things were
controversial you've apologized for
controversial statements right those
types of things what is your process for
fact checking and vetting the things
that you say in public I the the things
I say in public are the truth and that's
why they're so offensive to Democrat
activists in the media just like you and
you're asking me a blanket question with
no example I stand by the things that I
say I stand by oh she does does she
she's by the things she says she may
want to retract that statement she
should have just went with I don't
recall right well later on they're gonna
be like you said this thing during the
debate and she's like I don't recall
like there is a video footage like I
don't recall
um
it's it's juicy at best but um I mean
there's there's another clip there's
another clip what clip are you are you
we got I want to get to the Herschel
walk I I just want to show you yeah the
new Herschel Walker though is good I the
only thing I wanted to say was there's a
clip out there we don't have to play it
where Marjorie Taylor green goes uh she
goes back and forth with Marcus flowers
Marcus flower calls her out and was like
yo you were part of the Instagram pushed
it yeah
don't defame my character listen lady
you did it to yourself as soon as you
open your mouth and you're [ __ ]
wanting people to show up you did it to
yourself you were part of the problem
you pushed the big lie but I think the
favorite my favorite part of that is
when she goes my husband has the proof
okay as I as I said last night on
Twitter I was like Asterix uh soon to be
ex-husband double Asterix no he doesn't
Marge no he doesn't and if he did then
he would take it to I don't know the FBI
or law enforcement and to prove there
was fraud
no so just more [ __ ] that she was
spreading during that that debate but
anyway let's go back to Warnock versus
Herschel Walker it's fantastic it's I
can't even believe that that was the
real thing I was surprised it even
happened I am so happy that he did this
to believe it or not this is the best
thing ever because
he literally put himself in a situation
where he has to admit that now and he
keeps doubling that he's like no these
aren't fake badges these are just fake
badges like they're not they're not real
they're they're not fake they're real
fake they're really fake yeah he can't
he can't decide what this is I'm a real
cop right I'm a real boy it's [ __ ]
weird
watch Warnock though dunk on him here
and a lot of people uh gave Warnock a
lot of [ __ ] about this debate I didn't
watch the whole thing but um the the
most important thing to remember about
debates is there's only one moment
you're gonna pick out of the debate and
this is it so um Warnock wins this
debate only because of this moment
you can support police officers as I've
done through the cops program through
the invest to protect program while at
the same time holding police officers
like all professions accountable one
thing I have not done I've never
pretended to be a police officer
and and and I've never I've never
threatened a shootout with the police
now you see here I don't know if you can
see this we had herschel's digging in
his pocket he's like oh gotta get it
gotta get it
gotta where'd it go where did it go the
knock makes a good point like you can be
um uh make sure that you're funding
police departments make sure they get
good training make sure that the police
departments are there to uh I don't know
protect and serve the communities that
they're in
but still have the Nuance to go out and
to criticize them when they're not doing
those things and to say it's not right
for police departments in law
enforcement to do X Y and Z and we
should have policy that make sure that
they do not do X Y and Z there's a video
going around this morning of some cops
that got caught on their body cams
robbing a house when they were searching
holy [ __ ] I mean you know again
accountability is a [ __ ] and and no one
like and maybe that's what Herschel
Walker has in common with police
officers is most the time law
enforcement officials because they have
qualified immunity don't want
accountability
um but here the moderator holds Herschel
Walker pretends Sergeant numbnuts
Herschel Walker
um accountable for his actions almost
immediately because watch as he this is
the first time I think Herschel Walker
has pulled out anything
um in a long time
and now I have to respond to that yeah
we are moving on gentlemen respond to
that and you know what's so funny I am
with minute
there's the moment that everyone freezed
and captured
there he is he's holding
one of his many because he that he's
admitted this morning in this interview
right not only did he admit that this
check was actually his which he couldn't
deny I mean it's so it's so easy to know
that it's his check number one it's his
[ __ ] check it's his checking account
with his signature on it he's a [ __ ]
football player how many times has he
[ __ ] signed something
Christ and the other thing too
is that he has admitted that there's
many of these badges he is a law
enforcement officer with every law
enforcement agency that there possibly
could be you think of it you if you can
think of the law enforcement agency he's
got a plate toy badge from that agency
and he definitely is a commissioned
officer for sure maybe maybe really
maybe fake maybe really fake officer I'm
not sure
this is dumb this is [ __ ] stupid
right
it's it is incredibly dumb because
here's the thing what he has right now
and there's even an interview where he
doubled down on this he's like I got
this badge from the my local from his
hometown
and the sheriff was like yeah we gave it
to him but it's like for people who want
to have my like community service type
[ __ ] well they donated to the Sheriff's
right right but this is what this is
right now this is the same thing when
you're driving and you see something
with a with that they have a badge as a
bumper sticker on their car that's the
equivalency
Department which really in the end of
the day is you're hoping that the police
officer pulls you over on the side of
the road sees that and is like ah okay
I'll go a little bit more leaning on you
donated that's what Hershel Walker do
you think he carries this around just
for that just oh yeah he says he says he
carries it with them always oh my god
well watch watch as she the the
moderator just [ __ ] trashes him here
of course better than I ever could watch
what happens
and at the same time Mr Walker
excuse me Mr Walker
I need to let you know Mr Walker you are
very well yeah aware of the ruse tonight
yes and you have a prop that is not
allowed sir I ask you to put that prop
away well it's not a problem this is
real
oh my goodness
even in the moment she's like put that
fake ass [ __ ] she's like There are
rules and that's a prop this is not a
prop this is real is it though is it is
it real is it real are you a police
officer uh this is really [ __ ] dumb I
can't even believe this is real life to
be quite honest with you as soon as as
soon as live so I was uh I was out of
town this weekend and I was visiting
friends and we went to a comedy show and
I had no service during the comedy show
as soon as so I knew the debate
obviously was happening on a Friday
night but as soon as I got out it was
like bing bing bing bing bing I was
getting up from everything I messaged
you probably a hundred times like dude
you're not responding you gotta see this
Herschel Walker [ __ ] and I saw everyone
who was like tagging me and stuff and
sending me the photo and I was like this
can't be real he did not just pull out
this fake Toys R Us kindergarten cop
badge during this debate and then Double
Down On It
oh my God amazing amazing and I hope
that it does prove to people that he is
a clown and he is a joke and he's not
really qualified to be a senator of the
great state of Georgia
the guy is a [ __ ] clown and you know
as much as I hate Christian Walker and
what he stands for
when your son is calling you out who has
been you're what did he say something
about the badge no I'm just saying
original okay I don't know if he did or
not I was just saying originally in
terms of when I thought your voicemail
made a video about the badge no no no no
no I mean look I've got my own fake
badge that I use but it's a prop it's
literally a costume accessory item right
I wear it around when I want to be FBI I
wear it around when I want to be part of
it yes only it only matters your mindset
Gabe if you believe if you truly believe
I mean that's what Donald Trump told us
you are you just thinking if you think
speaking of senators who think [ __ ] that
isn't real that that to try to make it
become real
um and if you're in Wisconsin please go
vote against this [ __ ] I don't
care
um if you like Mandela Barnes or not
just vote against Ron Johnson that's all
I ask yeah because this guy is out of
his [ __ ] mind out of his mind now he
says something about
um leftist propaganda
and I said my left is propaganda 101
class was right before lesbian dance
Theory because he says in this clip that
basically
um people are being taught left is
propaganda in school it's really [ __ ]
weird but just listen debate on
Thursdays and pieces of it and when you
said you were set up by the FBI the
crowd laughed who was in that crowd and
have they been following the news do you
want to put that in context
well I think they they let in a bunch of
college students that we were supposed
to both get 50 oh my God okay college
students are allowed to go to debates
number one yeah they're allowed we
didn't want we didn't want these
youngins we wanted these old people
right like what the [ __ ] challenge
students can go to debates what are you
talking about
they let in college students they're not
allowed in debates everyone knows that
college students shouldn't vote what is
he uh and but listen to it gets really
Herschel walkery here real quick watch
audience members and the crowd was much
larger than that so my guess they're
they're college students who let's face
it our colleges they aren't exactly
teaching history they're really not
talking about you know the relevant
things that students really ought to
learn in college they're they're being
taught leftists of propaganda
unfortunately What did the
what
what the [ __ ] I mean okay I'll agree
that some colleges are more inclusive to
left-wing ideas right I'll agree with
that I'm fine with that there's a lot of
colleges out there that sensor speech
more than I think they should I'll agree
with that now most the time it's the
student organizations that are
self-censoring meaning they're saying we
don't want you here at our school and
it's their voice being heard right okay
now that's a little different than the
college axing it
and here's the thing
there is no leftist propaganda class in
college
no it's not a thing I thought it was but
all right and the craziest part about
this is that literally the America First
Nazis in this country are put are
putting themselves in a position where
their children
cannot be educated because they are
terrified that their children will go
learn everything they have told them is
[ __ ] lies yep like that he be that's
what he means when he's saying this is
that these kids went to school and
figured out you know what that [ __ ] that
my white parents said about black people
isn't real that [ __ ] that my white
parents said about people coming across
the border and living here and they're
they're here to take your jobs isn't
real because what happens is
is they uh experience what's the word
diversity in real life like they
discover it like they discover that oh
they're [ __ ] just humans they're just
Americans they just want the same [ __ ] I
want they want to have a cell phone they
want to listen to music they want to go
to the football game they want to get
drunk they want to have sex they want to
do drugs they want to watch TV they want
to they want to go have fun they want to
eat at a restaurant like they underst
they start to understand oh the [ __ ]
that I would all that [ __ ] I was told
every single [ __ ] bit of it that
Society fed me that racist Society fed
me as a white person is [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's all nonsense it's all garbage and
it's only to control
the the the narrative that there is
white supremacy in this country it is
institutional and that is why all white
people
all white people are racist
you that is why is because it's
institutional it is baked into you and
Ron Jackson Ron Johnson is saying here
is look white people
don't send your kid to college because
they're going to teach them the truth
which is left wing leftist propaganda
the truth that's what the truth is it's
[ __ ] ridiculous way just just if
you're in Wisconsin go go vote against
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] as a former
as a former resident of Wisconsin that's
right what university did you go to in
Wisconsin I went to Marquette University
Marquette University
just down the road from Dahmer right yep
yep just from the from the former well
it was it was afternoon yeah right but I
will say for anyone who still is in
Wisconsin because I still get people who
are like asking me to to phone bank for
them
um out of Wisconsin I'm anyone who's out
there please
protect the state of Wisconsin by
removing Ron Johnson it's uh there we go
protect the state of Wisconsin by
removing Ron Johnson Boom done there's a
slogan right there the guy is [ __ ]
terrible and also he's an
insurrectionist he tried to coo right
his way through only now only for a
couple minutes yeah only for a couple
minutes only for a couple minutes only
it was only a treasonous pieces I was
only in for like a second and then I
pulled out it's like two minutes of
trees yeah a couple pumps come in pumps
and I was done right not balls deep not
all the way in just the tip yeah um
speaking of just the tip uh
we have Charlie Kirk here he was on
stage at some [ __ ] Nazi rally on him
yeah another Turning Point USA I swear
they've got one like every weekend
they're getting desperate here the grift
the grift is real
turning points USA I don't know what I
don't know what it says behind him here
I'm not sure exactly where this is at
but this clip he is he is really upset
he's really upset Gabe about tolerance
he doesn't like tolerance he just
doesn't like it well he doesn't like
anything that goes against what he
believes well or goes against the actual
truth right but this goes to Zachary
what I was just saying about Ron Johnson
this goes exactly to this the threat is
the truth the threat is the truth that
equity and equality may only make sense
right when you think about it God forbid
we do the thing that this country has
founded to be right right
and it really pisses them off the
oppressor the oppressor gets really mad
when they don't get to oppress anymore
and they feel like here's here's here's
what they feel like I'm I'm a white dude
I know these [ __ ] here's what
they feel like
if
they get the ability to have the same
privileges I have they might treat me a
white man the way that I want to treat
them I can't even fathom I can't even
fathom it that's their thought I can't
fathom
someone treating me like I want to treat
them because it is so vile and such a
shitty position and a world view that I
can't imagine someone treating me like
that that's why they're saying it and
here's Charlie Kirk serving it up to me
on a platter here just listen
conservatives they say well tolerance is
a value I don't believe it is I don't I
believe you could have sympathy you
could have open-mindedness you can
entertain any idea I refuse to tolerate
evil
and I think far too many conservatives
have gone out of their way to being nice
you want to know my least favorite word
of 2022 is nice
okay if you're wondering if you're
wondering why Trump's statement on um on
fraud social is so
is such big news and why people should
be paying attention to it it's because
they're all doing the cat call they're
all doing it every single one of them
now you can do the thing that is most
important and you can you can make sure
to not be tolerant of intolerance
because that's that's the tricky part
about intolerance and tolerance
is you want to be tolerant of all ideas
you know he said I'm oh I'm I'm willing
to entertain the the ideas of
open-mindedness and the reason why he
says this [ __ ] the reason why this [ __ ]
box is saying this is to appeal to
people listening to my voice
who are for equality and Equity because
it's the Mind Trick it's the fascist
mind trick to hey you gotta you're
tolerant you're the tolerant left you
have to tolerate our ideas even though
our ideas are to exterminate you
are to get rid of you to marginalize you
to make that sure that you don't exist
what the [ __ ] are you talking about that
is not what we're gonna do what we're
gonna do is democracy we're gonna lean
into it we're gonna engage we're going
to use the ballot as a [ __ ] hammer
and we're gonna Crush these [ __ ]
Bashers we're gonna pile them on their
mountains of votes and it's up to you
you have to engage you have to not just
you have to make sure to vote you have
to make sure that three of your friends
your family are voting they have to make
sure that three are voting it is
something we have to do we must do this
in all places it doesn't matter what
state what district you're in whether
it's gonna go red or it's not gonna go
red listen I believe that Marjorie
Taylor green can still beat Marcus
flowers in that District even the dumb
[ __ ] that she said yep and the only way
is for anyone and everyone who has a
[ __ ] half a brain that realizes that
their best option for for representation
which is the reason why we vote in the
first place in a Democratic Republic is
Marcus flowers in that District
that is the only choice you have for
representation that is it
and it's up to you to engage and to keep
going and to press forward and not give
the [ __ ] up because I'm sick and tired
of sit hearing people say well Democrats
are just going to lose no they're not no
they're not stop at the defeatist
attitude lean into it punch a [ __ ]
Nazi in the mouth with your ballot that
is what you have to do they're telling
you out loud who they are what they are
and what they want to do it is up to you
I'll let you uh
have the mic there sorry
no I I agree 100 I mean yes punch down
the punch a Nazi down the ballot with
blue that's right okay we have to vote
blue like there is no tomorrow vote blue
and 22 that is the only way we can move
forward because the the right that you
hold so dear right now you know we we
don't speak or you know earlier this
year or last year you might go oh well
you guys are you guys are speaking in
hyperboles well here's the thing it's
not right the worst case scenario your
nightmare is actually a reality those
things are becoming true you know Blake
Masters wants to get rid of
contraception but now he's like whoa we
get a little we overstepped on the whole
abortion side so I'm gonna I'm gonna
scrape all those things from from my uh
from my website right
it's they want to complain about these
problems they want to complain about gas
inflation I mean I think it was Brian
Tyler Cohen that that shared an image
yesterday because uh Ted Cruz decided to
say that Democrats and inflation and
this is under Joe Biden's America in
like handshake emoji and uh Brian Tyler
calling let me see if I can find it then
Twitter's like oh when a here's
Republicans when it comes to actually
fighting inflation one side of the room
completely empty the other side of the
room full with Democrats who are willing
to actually put in the work to help us
Americans with the problems that are
going on right now well here's here's
just a simple vote a passage on access
to contraception right
194 Nays
two presents and seven no votes from
Republicans only eight Republicans only
eight
were willing to vote for access to
contraceptions
to make sure that it's codified that
people have access to contraceptions
that they're not trying to use Roe to
take away your right to contraception
it's [ __ ] crazy yeah but but they are
crazy they're [ __ ] nuts and they'll
take it away remember you know rights
for me but not for thee that's literally
what they're pushing for it's every
chance they get they will they will use
the money they will use the benefit they
will use the access that they have been
given but not share those things for
everyone else well it's it's what they
view is their freedom to oppress the
rights of other people and it's not
Liberty it's just what we say on the
show the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty it's not
it's not your right it isn't here's the
um here's the uh tweet that you had here
from right
Ted Cruz again you know wants to start
it off by saying oh well these are you
know President Biden 8.2 percent
inflation which by the way let's
understand inflation is also a global
thing that's happening in many countries
well he is responsible for the entire
world yeah right
into the world choosing gasoline
choosing this choosing that you know but
Brian Tyler Cohen comes in and says oh
Republicans skipping committee hearings
on inflation of course why would they
ever show up to actually do the things
to fix the problem they complain about
how many times has Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan tweeted about when are
we gonna have earrings on gas prices
right Real Americans Real Americans need
to have gas prices fixed and inflation
fix and need to be able to afford their
groceries here the Senators are having a
meeting on on [ __ ] inflation and not
one [ __ ] not one
I mean it's they say you know a
picture's worth a thousand words but
holy [ __ ] man there are no words on the
other side and the reason why they can't
show up to this meeting the reason why
they can't is they can't appear to be
working with Democrats to fix inflation
because it it'll it will it will
challenge people's brains to think you
know challenge their brains to think and
they can't have their base thinking
right they can't have it I mean it's the
same it's the same reason that we learn
during uh Thursday's Jan 6 hearing for
the day the ninth day is we learn that
President uh former president Trump one
term failure of a president Trump did in
fact admit and acknowledge privately
that he did lose the election and a way
to own the libs and pass the buck off to
someone else was an immediate with yeah
was an immediate withdrawal from
Afghanistan and Somalia right so the
they they basically put us in danger in
our dreams put us in danger and then as
soon as President Biden comes in they go
whoa whoa oh withdrawal from Afghanistan
that's basically going to be a [ __ ] show
and it's like yeah they literally warn
Trump don't do this because you're not
going to be in power next time around in
2022 or 2021
uh and you have to be the one
that that has to do like you're passing
it off to be like I don't have to worry
about it it's for the next guy you don't
care about people's lives you don't care
about Americans Republicans do not care
about Americans they don't care what the
hell like they don't care and whatever
happens to them as long as it benefits
them they get their money at the end of
the day they get to benefit and take
advantage of the situation and [ __ ] over
any American who's actually struggling
that's just completely kosher with them
here's how many Republican Senators care
about Americans right there right there
that's how many big fat goose egg is
what I see
ah [ __ ] them [ __ ] em I appreciate
everyone joining us today we could talk
for another three hours
we have so many clips and I'm sure
there's going to be so many clips from
today that are that are going to be
produced for tomorrow so and Texas
Paul's tomorrow you know it's Tuesday it
is Tuesday is Texas Pawn Taco Tuesday so
don't miss tomorrow
oh man it's just just do me a favor
everybody we're we're just we're three
weeks three weeks away lean into it all
the way the [ __ ] lean all the way
into your democracy start talking about
it like we say here let's talk about our
democracy to for a minute and tomorrow
we will do it
for 120 Minutes at least so join us
tomorrow same time same place YouTube
Twitter twitch Newton Eastern 11 Central
9 Pacific go visit store.beat Tony
michaels.com we have sold I don't know
we sold like four or five of these
already this morning whoa the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty we've got hoodies we got zip
up hoodies we got t-shirts we got coffee
mugs everyone loves this yeah this
design I think it's because they love
the idea because that's the idea of the
show is the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people it's not Liberty
and we're here to yell it scream it loud
and proud the same time same place
tomorrow be here
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon